all right we are back with Ross and
Wellington and it's finally time to
reveal their design by Drew apartment
makeover this morning before the show I
met you guys at the apartment yes super
early but we feel so loved Drew so loved
thank you so much
[Applause]
product we got you these because you
know how do you say thank you for
somebody changing your life and changing
your home we don't know how but flowers
are a start Drew I want to get on the
floor oh we're getting on the floor like
you do this is what you do on the show
[Applause]
I love you so much I thought you were
proposing to her like a throttle
situation I was like I was like well you
know this does work family so she's our
Mana all right let's see the reveal
all right
[Music]
this wallpaper I knew that we could make
a dining room out of this area can we
talk about the light fixture oh my God
the light fixture is so cute I just put
this curio cabinet here and we have
benches do you know what this gives me
like we talked about what the Charlotte
York Round Table in her entryway we have
her round table for flowers but you can
like sit oh my God I love this table
this mirror opens us up so much when I
walk in also the first thing you see is
you can see yourself or check yourself
before you're leaving you know what I
call that a last looks mirror it
inspired me to get this Indigo colored
fabric when you look in the mirror
you'll see this Moroccan fabric
reflected instead of a washing machine
oh my God oh my God the noise I just
made for a washer dryer I actually hid
the wall panel for the electrical
circuit with these sort of like Chic
pieces of wall art Gorge
let me show you the closet do you have
no idea how excited
we got this from modular closet it's
crisp and modern and you can totally
organize everything beautifully I really
wanted to have two folding chairs so we
fit comfortably and cozy over there you
could literally have
three four five six seven people sit
here I'm actually obsessed with this
space through this is unbelievable I
love it come look at the kitchen
oh my God
I love the appliances oh my God look at
those backsplash
so we worked with full circle Market
because wellness and health is so
important thanks to them we were able to
stock an entire Pantry with a beautiful
well-made well-crafted healthy wholesome
food with amazing ingredients oh my God
okay I cannot believe you painted the
cabinets but it looks brand new good I
love that you painted them white I just
thought a third color was too much
totally and I brought in your pieces of
art over there those are the beautiful
pots and pans look at our new appliances
I know look at this stunning dishwasher
I could not love this beco stove more
it's really Chic this stunning fridge
that is just a perfect fit hello there's
a party in our fridge have you seen the
blue light I know
you ready you ready for us
[Music]
oh oh my God oh my God this is so crazy
beautiful
oh my gosh I'm getting chilled above the
couch I've never seen anything like that
that is the most beautiful collection
I'm in love with this leather ottoman
that acts as a coffee table by the way
because it gives us the Cozy that we
need I have to tell you too we tried
five tables they were all the weirdest
shape and then the patina but then the
leg this one has brass it's open it's
sturdy
[Music]
I'm gonna snuggle you this is like
in such a small space it's about
creating comfort and creating spaces you
know so uptight about all of this I
cared so much thank you so much honestly
first you were a flower girl and now you
did this
it's like you're my Mana my sister oh my
God you're my hermana I
the bed frame which I found you guys
this is so Chic it's like you're in a
hotel suite that's what I wanted I
wanted Hotel living this should be like
your pieta Terra Hotel yes I wanted to
be conscious about bringing in some
Earth Tones and so I got these little
pieces of art I absolutely love it it's
perfect oh and then I put this chair
here because it fits so perfectly when
people come over you have a conversation
pit and then don't forget so now you
have your division this is such a smart
way to divide this space I want to try
hello
[Laughter]
I just have to tell you you've changed
us in so many ways you've taken your
magic wand and put it on this little
square and turned it into this
we were gonna wake up every morning and
think of you I love you so much I did
want to make you guys a home
because
you have changed my life so profoundly
you know I know I wanted this apartment
to be a visual reminder of like how you
really
transformed my life when you came to the
show thank you so much Drew for making
this this little squirrel I love you
both so much
when's our first slumber party
we'll be right back okay
[Music]